buenos días
hoy les vengo a hablar de algo que no se
ve pero que se siente y se vive es algo
que muchos pueden percibir de otra
manera y que hay muchos paradigmas en
torno a esto les vengo a hablar de un
arcoiris de posibilidades como está
buscando que tengo hoy que tiene miles
de fibras y miles de intersecciones así
son las personas en el espectro autista
hay miles de posibilidades dentro del
espectro
estoy involucrada con el espectro
autista desde hace más o menos un año en
que a mi hijo de 12 años lo
diagnosticaron con rasgos del espectro
autista para mí fue muy difícil fue un
proceso largo fue un proceso tedioso
pero fue un proceso muy importante no
sólo para él sino también para mí
el hecho de descubrir que él estaba en
el espectro trajo muchas respuestas y le
ayudó muchísimo y ahora es un niño más
feliz está más empoderado de y tiene más
consciencia de sus limitaciones y de sus
potencialidades
mi hijo cuando era pequeño tuvo
problemas para comenzar a hablar
estaba expuesto a dos idiomas y se
atribuyó al bilingüismo su falta de
deber validad después de que comenzó a
hablar en portugués porque vivíamos en
brásil un día de repente dejó de hablar
durante tres meses
no saben la preocupación como madre todo
lo que sentí dije y ahora y si mi hijo
nunca más vuelve a hablar pues después
de tres meses comenzó a hablar otra vez
pero tartamudeando un proceso largo tuve
que estudiar muchísimo para saber cómo
corregirlo sin arriesgar que se quedara
tartamudo de por vida
desde que era bebé era alérgico a la
leche
desde que era muy pequeño también tenía
muchos problemas gastrointestinales y
muchas muchas cosas asociadas era muy
tímido no sonreía las personas me decían
que había algo malo con él pero yo decía
no él es mi hijo y él está muy bien y es
muy inteligente y punto pues el tiempo
fue pasando
vivimos en eeuu también y en todos los
colegios donde mi hijo estaba me decían
que me llegaban los reportes diciendo
felipe es muy tímido no participa en
clase no tiene amigos no quiere hacer
trabajos en grupo pero es muy
inteligente y eso entonces a mí me
dejaba tranquila y decía ok está muy
bien está muy inteligente todo está bien
ya hablaba tres idiomas cuando tenía
cinco años hablaba portugués español e
inglés entonces no pues este niño es
súper inteligente también tenía
habilidades o tiene habilidades
musicales tocaba el violín y en una
orquesta en brásil tocaba el piano
entonces muchas de sus características y
esa timidez que tenía para mí eran
normal
y yo simplemente lo aceptaba como era
pero había cosas super raras que sólo
ahora cuando él
cuando estábamos en este proceso de
diagnóstico fue que percibí que me di
cuenta porque tuve que hacer un como un
levantamiento de toda su historia desde
desde pequeño había una cosa súper
interesante cuando nos fuimos a vivir a
eeuu
tenía que usar medias porque en brásil
andábamos en chanclas
y en eeuu era un problema salir de la
casa porque nos podíamos demorar dos
horas para que se vistiera y se pusieran
medias y zapatos las medias le
incomodaban
cuando íbamos de viaje en el carro se
ponía a llorar y a gritar porque le
incomodaba el sonido de la radio
muchos me decían que era un niño mimado
que yo le estaba mal criando y todo esto
pero no es así
estar en el espectro autista primero que
todo no es una enfermedad como muchas
personas lo han malinterpretado
y estar en el espectro como les decía
son muchas posibilidades entonces no
siempre vamos a encontrar las mismas
características de la misma manera en
todas las personas por eso es tan
difícil el diagnóstico
bueno cuando después de que mi hijo pasó
por muchos test de sangre tests
psicológicos encefalogramas resonancias
magnéticas una neuropsicóloga nos dio el
informe de más de 15 páginas en el cual
dice que mi hijo tiene hipersensibilidad
táctil hipersensibilidad auditiva y
dificultades para socializar
esto simplemente para mí fue algo
esclarecedor
algo muy útil para poder forjar su
futuro para poder ayudarlos a
sobrellevar esas dificultades ya
potencializar las que tiene porque
también su coeficiente intelectual es
mucho más alto en algunos aspectos como
en las matrices en el lenguaje y tiene
problemas en otras áreas del
conocimiento también
entonces todo este proceso me llevó a
buscar grupos de apoyo porque para
hacerles sincera el día en que tuve el
diagnóstico lloré lloré porque dije cómo
es posible que yo como madre nunca me di
cuenta que mi hijo tenía algo que
necesitaba ser visto para poder ayudarlo
me sentí culpable porque dije yo debería
haberlo llevado antes a un psicólogo
haberme preguntado por qué sus actitudes
porque sus
temas porque sus complicaciones porque
no quería salir al centro comercial
porque no quería ir a las fiestas de los
amiguitos
pero
después de estar en estos grupos y de
darme cuenta que otras mamás estaban
pasando por lo mismo simplemente dije
esto es bueno esto es bueno ahorita
saber porque mientras más temprano
sepamos que un familiar nuestro está
dentro del espectro es mucho mejor
porque tenemos más tiempo de ayudar lo
más tiempo de incluir lo más tiempo de
concientizar a los demás
entonces yo decidí que iba a hablar
sobre el autismo
porque hay muchas personas que pasan
toda su vida sin saber que están en el
espectro hay personas que les
diagnostican a los 12 años muy típico
por la entrada a la secundaria que fue
lo que le pasó a mi hijo a otras
personas los diagnostican a los 15 18 y
hay adultos también que han sido
diagnosticados a los 20 25 30 35 años
qué quiere decir esto que hay muchos
muchas personas en el espectro que están
por ahí sin saber que están en el
espectro
y sería muy importante que la gente se
concientice
después de estar todo este tiempo ya ha
pasado casi un año hace pocos meses
también me di cuenta que yo estoy en el
espectro después de investigar tanto y
de leer sobre cómo se presenta el
autismo en las mujeres me di cuenta que
yo también estoy en el espectro
justamente ahí la mala concepción de que
solo los hombres sufren autismo o están
dentro del espectro y que no las mujeres
esto se da porque en las mujeres el
autismo todas las características se
presentan de manera más sutil y las
mujeres tienen una capacidad
extraordinaria diferente digamos de
aprender a imitar las acciones sociales
o el convivio social por eso pueden
pasar desapercibidas y nadie puede puede
que nadie lo note y muchas mujeres nunca
fueron diagnosticadas
en este momento y yo estoy buscando una
persona que me diagnostica porque no hay
profesionales que diagnostiquen adultos
y mucho menos mujeres
pero les voy a contar un poquito de cómo
estar en el espectro a mí me afectó
durante toda mi vida cuando era pequeña
sufrí muchísimo de bullying
no encajaba en ningún grupo no tenía
amigas en el colegio tenía una
imaginación tan extraordinaria que
terminé inventándome historias que
afectaban a personas adultas en mi
entorno
pero quizás por estar
en el espectro pude dedicarme más a mis
estudios porque no me interesaba mucho
salir no tenía amigos entonces me
dediqué a estudiar
y bueno después de todo este tiempo que
ha pasado después de 35 años cuando me
entero que yo estoy en el espectro fue
muy esclarecedor para mí me di cuenta de
que cualquier persona
está en el espectro
puedes sobrellevar cualquier cosa se
puede lograr cualquier cosa
a pesar de todo lo que me pasó en mi
infancia mi adolescencia e inclusive en
mi vida adulta porque hasta ahora tengo
algunos rezagos de todo esto y en mi
trabajo anterior tuve un día aún
como un ataque de ansiedad y eso fue una
de las cosas que me hizo dar cuenta pero
ya claro esto fue hace tres años y
después de tres años um y los puntos y
dije esto fue una crisis de ansiedad por
los estímulos que estaba recibiendo en
ese momento
entonces
lo que quiero dejarles claro es que si
tienen algún familiar algún amigo que
ustedes puedan percibir que tiene estas
características busquen ayuda porque
negaré un diagnóstico no es bueno lo
mejor es intentar tener un diagnóstico
para poder saber quién soy yo
para poder
potencializar las capacidades y luchar
contra las dificultades
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]